(male announcer)
This program is presented
by University of California
Television.
Like what you learn?
Visit our website or follow us
on Facebook and Twitter
to keep up with
the latest UCTV programs.
♪
(man)
This is the Thinkabit Lab.
It's a dedicated maker space
for middle school students
to experience work at Qualcomm
as well as experiencing
engineering
in a personal, hands-on way.
(woman)
After a lot of research,
we found that sixth, seventh,
and eighth grade students,
they lose their passion
for math and science.
Whether it's
"science isn't cool,"
especially for girls,
math isn't cool,
there's a transitional period
between eighth and ninth grade.
So we said, "What if we show
that engineering's fun,
that science and math is fun,
that the concepts
they're learning
can be transferred
into a real-world job?"
(Hidalgo)
STEM or STEAM:
science, technology,
engineering, and math.
If you add "A,"
you get STEAM, the arts.
Around the Thinkabit Lab,
you'll see art all around us.
Why should Qualcomm
do this?
Well, we're a leader here,
one of the largest private
employers in our community.
It's important
for a business
to be connected
to education.
More and more, we've heard that
business isn't engaged enough.
Oftentimes, businesses engage
in the form of check-writing,
but this is a way to give back
in a personal way.
They want local San Diegans
to work for Qualcomm.
Ultimately, they want to ignite
the passion in kids,
so we have a similar vision.
And working alongside people
who are for education,
it's really powerful.
(woman)
Once the kids arrive,
they have to be quiet
because it is
a working environment.
I can imagine what
they're feeling coming here.
"We got to be quiet.
How serious is this?"
And they immediately go
into the World of Work room.
(Cline)
How's everyone doing?
Are you guys excited?
Yes.
It's going to be
an awesome day.
At Qualcomm, 31,000 people
working on these technologies,
and the main portion of them
are engineers.
We'll give you
a taste of engineering
today at Thinkabit Lab.
(Hidalgo)
The question
we often ask is,
"How do children aspire to
careers they don't know exist?"
We talk about work at Qualcomm
and other big companies,
how their interests and values
map out to these careers.
And really, we emphasize
engineering, obviously,
being a tech company,
but here in this space, we
talk about support functions,
marketing, graphic design,
finance, legal,
business development,
user-interface designers.
We're starting
to put these words
into middle school brains,
and it's really cool to see.
We're not trying to push
kids into STEM fields.
We do believe that STEM
capability will be critical
for all workers in the future,
in 21st century careers.
To understand technology,
whether you're a lawyer
or an accountant
or a human resources
professional,
we need to know
and understand technology.
STEM will influence all careers,
and that's what we encourage.
I like to synchronize the class
before we get started.
How we do that is we get in
one circle and hold hands.
(Naderi)
We use this giant battery,
and I explain a circuit only
works as a complete circuit,
so they have to hold hands.
They see immediately
what a complete circuit does
and how, if you let go,
it'll stop working.
That's just how
the circuit works.
Disconnect.
Oh, it is not conductive
through cloth.
But it's only because
there's not enough voltage.
If the voltage was higher,
it may be going through cloth.
The longer one is positive.
The shorter one is negative.
From there, we have them
building a basic circuit,
which is an LED turning on.
It's actually really cool.
Never underestimate
an LED turning on,
how exciting that is
for somebody.
I did it!
Engineers will come in
'cause they're curious,
so we introduce them.
This engineer works
on the Snapdragon chip
that's in the latest phones,
or who created
the 4K technology.
So really bringing
that kind of abstract idea
of what an engineer is or
who a Qualcomm professional is,
bring them in and say,
"This is what they look like."
There's a difference between me
rambling about jobs and college
and actually seeing people
who went to college,
our engineers
and people like them,
especially having a female
like Sarah at Qualcomm
being the lead engineer
and teaching them.
That's powerful for girls to
see that they can do this too.
We get an LED to blink
using the code from the Arduino.
I like this part of the day
because we not only expose them
to engineering and coding,
but also challenge them
with something
they're not familiar with.
That's it.
That is all my code.
They've learned basics of
the Arduino and the breadboard
and how to code.
The idea of what was code
was very foreign to them
and understanding
it's just numbers.
You're telling
something what to do
and then coding it
into this Arduino
and actually
seeing an LED blink
because you told it
to do that
really opens a door for them.
Oh, my God,
it's magic!
It's blinking.
It's magic!
(Naderi)
And they're all exposed to,
that coding can
affect your system,
that it's not as hard
as they thought,
and that it was a lot more fun
than they thought it would be.
I get the "I-thought-this-
would-be-boring" impression
and can't tell you how many
times I've heard kids tell me,
"This was more fun
than I thought."
One girl whispered, "I thought I
was going to be a computer nerd.
This is fun."
I was like, "I don't know why
you're whispering, but awesome!"
So this one is
a regular servo.
From there,
we go into servos immediately
and try to get both the servos
to work a full rotation.
The full rotation goes around.
Regular ones go back and forth.
And so then after
that exercise, it's free game.
They choose one servo
and go to the craft store
and actually build out
their entire project.
I'm amazed
what kids come up with.
They don't have limits.
Any product that is worthy
had to go through
some artistic process.
So the powerful thing
about STEAM
is that the art allows kids
the platform to be
whoever they want.
It's not forcing them
to create a rigid product
in any way, shape, or form.
To give these kids that
flexibility and empowerment,
it's probably the first time
in their childhood
that they get to own something
that's completely theirs.
They got to manifest it
from their imagination
through and through.
[kids laughing]
There's no doubting
the change in students
after they come
into the lab.
For sure, they didn't think
they would be coding
or would be creating
a robotic craft.
When they exit the lab,
they are almost more energized
than when they came in.
Kids that walk in like this...
"Yeah, I can do that."
And they leave like...
It's like this ginormous smile,
like they are just lit up.
I think this space can provide
proof to our peers in society
that you can ease people
into traditionally difficult
subject matters.
And not only is it fun,
the kids like it,
the adults putting it together
like it,
and it really is
a win-win-win situation.
Many schools have said, "Since
coming to the Thinkabit Lab,
we're motivated
to create our own lab.
That was our hope,
that schools would be
interested to create a space
dedicated to engineering
and science and coding,
so students could have
regular accessibility.
Schools like Monarch School,
e3 Charter,
Feaster Team Charter,
those schools
are making inroads
to create their own
maker spaces.
(Motsinger)
What we're doing at Feaster
is exciting,
it's innovating, it's engaging,
and it's exposing our kids
to a variety of opportunity.
They wanted to get involved
right from the beginning.
Their superintendent,
their principal,
their staff
have been phenomenal
because they've been open
to listening to our thoughts,
as we've been open
to listening to theirs.
It's a perfect collaboration.
As we've grown,
we have helped each other both.
They came here and helped us
develop our own engineering lab.
We are so fortunate to send
some students to Qualcomm,
but we have 1,200 students,
and our kindergartners,
first-graders, second-graders,
all of our kids wanted
to have that experience.
A lot of what I've been working
with is constructive struggle.
They have problems.
Things don't work out
as planned,
and so it's how do we
figure this out
and trying let them think
and work through it.
(girl)
It gave me a way
to see things differently
and to work in hard situations
where you have to show grit
and have another way
to look at things,
instead of being,
"I'm done. I can't do that."
I want them to
take away the process.
It isn't one thing or
one project or one idea.
It's more about the process
that they go about thinking
because it translates so well
from what they're doing here
into real-world,
real-life situations.
(girl)
When you're stuck and see
somebody building something,
you can take that
and put it into yours,
then take part
of something else,
and it would
significantly help you
because it just builds
your creativity off of them.
(Motsinger)
I walk in, and eyes don't turn
to see who came in the door.
They are focused,
they're engaged,
they're talking to each other,
they're communicating,
they're collaborating.
Three years ago, if I asked
a child what they wanted to be,
you'd hear "football player"
or "basketball player,"
"a dancer."
Things that they relate to
and see in their community.
Now we hear kids saying
they want to be engineers,
or they want to be scientists
or want to work in forensics.
This type of vocabulary
they didn't have before
nor this type of inspiration.
They didn't have
the knowledge before
because they weren't
exposed to it.
Success to me means
that we've inspired a child
who may not have known before
what they wanted to do.
I feel successful
if a kid comes back excited
and wanting to learn more
about a specific topic
or wanting to work on a project
that before they saw as
just a task or assignment.
When they're engaged,
when they're excited
about something,
to me, that's success.
Funding to purchase and make
this educational production
accessible was provided by the
U.S. Department of Education:
PH: 1-800-USA-LEARN (V)
or WEB: www.ed.gov.
♪